j'allais danser
et
elle dit aussi dans cet été danse
elle a marqué de ça
Nico la chanteuse la plus mystérieuse de
l'histoire de la pop musique est à Paris
ces projets chanter avec John Kell et
Lou Reed ses anciens partenaires du
fameux Velvet Underground
de convivi le premier à Londres la
semaine prochaine le deuxième à Paris
dans 15 jours voici Nico pour pop 2
[Musique]
comment est-ce que tu as rencontré Louis
de John Kell avec qui tu veux jouer au
début du Velvet un de guarnia 4 ans
comment est-ce que tu les as rencontrées
le café bizarre
je suis très très impressionné mais à
quel moment au début le plus la plus
belle
passage de ma vie c'était quand
il y a 5 ans avant que le Velvet
Underground soit formé tu as rencontré
Andy
[Musique]
je l'avais rencontré chez Castel
j'allais danser
et elle dit aussi avec ses amis
et on dansait tous ensemble
dans cet été danse
elle a marqué de ça de
dans salam
c'est très perversé ton premier disque
girl on trouve en importation dans
certaines boutiques de disques à Paris
en France et puis on trouve bien sûr les
disques avec le Velvet le disque avec le
Velvet et puis les deux autres disent
que tu as fait par la suite mais à part
ça tu n'as rien enregistré d'autres
est-ce que tu prépares un disque
maintenant en ce moment
enrichi enregistré rien d'autre tu
penses pas que ça suffit déjà pour
je peux très bien me retirer
non
j'aimerais bien jouer à l'Opéra un jour
qu'est-ce que tu as fait pendant après
que tu aies quitté le Velvet Underground
c'est à dire il y a 4 ans à peu près et
puis maintenant où tu recommences à
chanter toute seule ou avec d'autres tu
as refait du cinéma
de toute manière ma musique
je pense toujours au théâtre et au
cinéma
en même temps et je pense que
[Musique]
une musique très visuelle tu as tourné
dans un film français il y a pas
longtemps
où il a cicatrice intérieure c'est c'est
un film
[Musique]
psychologique
en même temps que
[Musique]
du théâtre classique
du théâtre grec classique
qui est le réalisateur de ce film le
metteur en scène de la cicatrice
intérieure
français
[Musique]